this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 69 sitting here with EC
Echo Charles yes
Echo Charlie sure sometimes referred to
let me drop a will link up so we're
gonna talk about choking
but normally we talk about choking we're
talking about the jujits right that's
her that when we think of choking that's
what we think of but there's another
form of choking
and that's when the chips are down
you know what I'm saying the stakes are
high mistakes are high choking in sports
or in any kind of event you know you can
choke in a debate you can choke in a
confrontation with someone
an argument
but it's what it is
failing to perform
as one is expected to perform
based on how they have performed in the
past and the skill level that they have
so because here's the thing if someone
loses
or someone who loses all the time or
isn't that good doesn't make any goals
and now they miss a game-winning shot
right that's not that's not choking yeah
yeah that's just true that's just
someone that sucks right but when
someone is good
then someone does perform well and they
do score goals and they do that
historically and consistently and and
then that moment comes for them to make
that game-winning shot and they miss it
yeah that's joking
happens in every sport happens in uh
basketball
right
especially foul shots yeah you know what
I'm saying yes I do my uh one of my best
friends in the terms he was
he was playing in like the he was either
I think it was the state finals and he
and he had a foul shot to make for the
win and he missed the finals we missed
it and they lost
field goals in football yeah JV we're
playing against
was the kicker for one minute by the way
our cake nuts
so you guys are on opposing team
supposing teams and they're better than
us straight up but we held them to zero
zero the whole game nice so they had the
ball last play of the game one second
left field goal time for them okay nuts
runs up on the field I'm like looking at
this guy and kick that's good you guys
are friends right now at this point at
that point at that point you were
friends friends yeah yeah for sure not I
mean not as much as we were like uh you
know later on later yeah this is JV time
actually we weren't friends okay I
didn't meet him till
like I met I knew him but we didn't
become friends friends till 10th grade
so
um so yeah he runs over the fields cake
now to this little run he used to play
for 100 by the way which is in Pop
Warner anyway so you get someone there
he lines up freaking and it wasn't that
far of a field goal it was like 20 yards
not even 15 maybe yeah so he gets on
there and bro he kicks it makes it oh he
made it did not choke okay well there
you go but I thought he was gonna choke
out because you know like he was so
poetic they were supposed to beat us so
bad he didn't joke though King nuts for
the win
haunting
archery
he this is a this is a total like this
will be revealed yeah to use Echo
Charles's second favorite word revealed
you're you know you there's guys
you shoot you go out and shoot your bow
70 80 90 100 yards 110 yards yeah just
out there you're just dialed in hitting
that me and Josh Hall Josh Hall and I
have the gotta hit that paper plate at
60 yards every time right so that's what
that's where you're at yeah and if you
can hit a paper plate at 60 yards you
should be able to hit that elk in the
Kill Zone at 60 yards
but then all of a sudden a guy will come
out they'll go out and they'll Miss at
30 yards yeah
you know it is it is tough and there's
all kinds so what's causing that you got
heightened anxiety
there's adrenaline going through so you
got you got the chemical cocktail that
could be going through your system you
got the the anxiety you got could have
the negative thoughts like if I miss
you might be worrying about things that
you can't control you might be over
processing all the things that are
happening you got one thing to think
about yeah
you got the social expectations yeah
right like
you're if there's a cry I mean what
about when the crowds there right
everyone's watching yeah
where I go hunting normally
everybody knows like you come back to
camp and everybody knows what happened
there's no hiding it yeah
uh
so those are the kind of things that
can cause problems yeah right that can
cause you to choke now what's
interesting is there is
something called the individual zones of
optimal functioning and that is what
that means is in certain amount of
stress is good
because you have to focus more like
here's here's one
um I most of the time surf without a
leash without a rope
leashes are for dogs well right I don't
know no not just for dogs but you know
so here's the thing when when I this is
one of those things that
you know there's certain things that you
can feel like you can actually feel them
like let's say what do you
like let's say you work on a computer a
lot right sure if your computer's
lagging like you'll notice it I probably
wouldn't notice it I understand if I was
trying to do something I wouldn't notice
it because you're so good at working
your computer that you're going to
notice when it's lagging so when you can
actually identify something I actually
feel
like when I'm surfing and I don't have a
leash on yeah actually I feel it more
when I when I if I have a leash on I'm
like can I even just feel this like
crazy Carefree like I'll just do
whatever and you feel a lot looser and a
lot less focused when you're out on a
big day with no rope your is tight
you are focused yeah you have to be
because if you blow it your board's gone
yeah you may you might have to swim for
it you may lose it this is you may never
see it again so
that
that that's what you want a certain
amount of stress in this scenario so
how the question is like how do we
overcome choking what can we do what can
we do to stop that well obviously
detach
you can't get all caught up in your head
breath take a breath right breathe
take a breath man calm down you gotta
calm down here's another critical thing
have a protocol like a protocol when we
would learn to shoot
we would some some guys would make like
a little ditty is that word is that a
civilian word does anybody know what
that means yeah yeah like a little thing
like a little it doesn't rhyme but it's
like a certain little chant yeah a
little something I when I first started
archery I had it oh for real you know I
I mean I definitely had it for shooting
before but the most recent little ditty
that I had was for archery and it was
just like I went through the whole you
know starting at my feet I was like feet
in position and I went all the way up to
like pinky on the I I would touch my to
keep my front hand you believe it or not
when you shoot in Bow your front hand is
like loose you don't grip uh because
that torques the bow so I'd be like
pinky touch and I would just like touch
my pinky onto the onto the bow itself
because I knew that if I went to touch
it and I was gorilla gripping oh you're
gross so so you make these little
ditties and they will
they will help you
um with that and and look you can also
have things that are protocols like when
someone goes take a foul shot in
basketball
did you play basketball no so I played
basketball you know you go out and I had
like if it was a foul shot I'd have my
little like spin the ball bounce spin
the ball bounce bounce bounce shoot so
you have a little protocol that you're
going through
that's really good
uh what can you do to put yourself in
pressure situations because the more you
get into pressure situations the better
you can be in handling them that's when
I was running SEAL training it was like
we're gonna put you in insane pressure
situations Mayhem situations and you're
going to start to learn how to do these
things and of course practicing
which is because the lack of confidence
can trigger you to choke because you
lack confidence and you choke how do you
get more confident you get good you
practice the more you practice the more
your confidence increases even doing
mental rehearsals of what you're gonna
do
is going to help out
uh
I would say
I we heard I heard this originally
that it had to do with Tiger Woods coach
Tiger Woods mental coach
and his thing was it's not your last
shot you can't think about your last
shot you can't think about your next
shot you just have to like clear your
mind and think about this shot right
here where this becomes very evident is
if you're shooting drills like pistol
and you're shooting six head plates
if you miss one of those yeah this is
where you see where a guy's head is at
right because he goes he goes ping ping
ping bang like a miss so it's like hit
hit hit miss a guy that's good just no
Factor takes another shot at that Target
moves right on down the line no Factor
but you'll see sometimes guys it's just
everything falls apart it's like hit hit
hit miss miss miss miss miss miss miss
miss
mag change you're just like oh my God
so that that is one of the things that I
think really applies
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not sub object to
their control and we're doing it so we
can give you more control more
interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground